thank you for joining us America we're
glad you are here open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money
andrew is with us in Seattle hey Andrew
how are you hey I'm doing well Dave
thanks so much for taking my call and
thanks for what you do thank you how can
I help sir
well I have been in my first job out of
college here just for three and a half
months now and yesterday I was fortunate
to receive a job offer from a clinic
that I had applied to higher to getting
this employment and they're asking me if
I would come over there mmm clinic
you're a doc I am a veterinarian a
veterinarian okay and why would you
leave a lot of it has to do with the
compensation and benefits package so
okay so what are you making now I make
$60,000 a year and what would you make
over there
the base would be seventy thousand
although they had told me that after
about 90 days it would go to a
production based schedule which would
result in what well if I did as well as
I did last month at my current clinic I
would make about 120 vows given that's
not every month that was a busier month
but even on average so this other clinic
is going to double your income some
month yes okay I'm sorry I so I'm in one
month a year or what what is it what is
your income potential what do you really
think you're going to make at the new
place in a year 85 to 90 instead of 60
yes then you're locked in at 60 you
don't get 60 plus production correct and
so I don't think my question is
necessarily do I take this other job the
question I really have is how do I talk
to my current boss who's been my mentor
for nine years and who thinks I mean I
think he gets the impression I'm staying
long-term how do I even have this
conversation I want to do the right
thing I don't want to leave him high and
dry but at the same time I just had a
child you know we have a lot of debt to
conquer and this is what we need to
you I don't know how to how to approach
this with him okay I'm still stuck on
the fact that you're a hundred percent
sure you need to do it I want to I want
to circle one more time for I land the
plane okay upon your your production
your compensation package at the old
place is not going to make you a dime
more than sixty thousand in the coming
12 months correct the other place the
projection is 85 yes and up from there
probably correct why are they willing to
pay you so much more I don't know and
that's a really good question and part
of it I wonder is if my being employed
and being mentored by this particular
individual for the last better part of a
decade you know if you just as trouble
see me as a professional or can't
compensate me and I say have only been a
DVM for three and a half months but
you've been working there just helping
him up until then correct yes okay well
that's possible that's possible well the
way to answer these questions are just
change shoes okay
yeah you've mentored a young guy all the
way from high school cleaning out cages
all the way up till he gets his DVM he's
been working for you through three and a
half months you care about him he's got
a baby
he's got veterinarian student loans and
and he works for you making 60 and he's
got an opportunity to make 85 if I'm in
that guy's shoes I'm happy for you
wouldn't you be if you had a young man
you had mentored and you'd want him to
make more and when right yes
now if there's some things that have
been unsaid and he starts saying them
like I'd like to match that then you've
got a different you know a different
scenario to look at and and I was kind
of hoping you'd buy into this practice
in the future and in the meantime I'd
like to match the production to get you
out of student loan debt
I hadn't really thought about it I
thought starting you at sixty was fair
but apparently the markets higher than I
realized
then that gives you something to stop
and think about so you know what I'm
going to do is just approach it from the
angle of how would I want to be treated
if I were him if you were him how would
you want you to treat you I want you to
come in and be very grateful for what's
happened so far and just go I know you
care about me and I know that and I
appreciate all you've invested into me
and you know I've got all these loans
and you know that extra twenty five
thousand dollars is a lot I've got to
take this unless you give me some kind
of reason to not take it and you're my
mentor I trust you I think you would
tell me to take this this is you talking
to him exactly right and I recall you
saying something similar in the past to
another caller I just don't want I don't
want to change the relationship by
asking for this bump or using the offer
as leverage no I mean just say that then
just say that just say that I'm not in
here to blackmail you I'm in here in a
very awkward conversation I think I need
to take this job right this is who I
need and it's and it's awkward because I
because I am so grateful for all you've
done for me right but I'm not so
grateful that I'm gonna sit here my
twenty five thousand dollars a year less
nor what I think you'd want to because
want me to cuz you're a man of integrity
well if I'm not happy there then he
doesn't want me for a year or two years
you know it's there to break off early I
think yeah but I think if he's a real
mentor now if he's using all of this to
try to get cheap labor then you may get
a different reaction out of him and you
can't control his reaction all you can
control how you approach it
but you approach it with class and
dignity and gratitude and and in no way
infer that that he should match it but
if he starts doing that then you should
listen right and say well I'm happy to
talk about that but I wouldn't want to
come in here and blackmail you our
relationship or negotiate with you our
relationship means too much to me to use
this as leverage on you and so I just
assumed I was supposed to take this but
if you want to talk about it we'll talk
about it but no I'm not going to stay at
60 okay no that's very helpful and the
worst he can do is fire me right yeah
yeah and he's not going to and it is
easy a jerk
not generally there are some there's
some suspect stuff and kind of red flags
and a different culture at the other the
newer facilities I'd be going to that
there's a lot of intangibles as well but
make it a better better deal well I mean
it may be that that he has been using
all of this as leverage on you in which
case you may get a very negative you owe
me you're my slave reaction and you
can't control that all you can do is
control you and how you've approached it
okay and the other thing I didn't
mention is I have attempted to negotiate
in the past and I didn't get any they
didn't budge whatsoever so that kind of
sends me a little bit of a message yeah
yeah you could just say that you know I
tried and and and I this thing came up
and you know I had talked to them before
I talked to you and they came back I
wasn't out searching but they came over
and dropped it in my lap and you know I
had a young man leave here the other day
they don't he doubled his income I can't
say anything to him except just awesome
good for you otherwise I'm being selfish
and I'm just thinking about me I mean
gosh I mean this guy's got a young
family and doubled his dadgum income
I'll help you pack your desk you know
it's just a good for you man I'm sorry I
don't want him to leave but I you know
I'm not matching that I'm gonna talk
about it
good luck with that I hope it works and
you know but you know it's it's
incumbent upon him to have class in the
conversation as well and you can't
control that and you can't be
manipulated by the background in terms
of you staying in an untenable situation
either so I think you're taking the
thing and I hope my only hope is is that
he reacts in a gentlemanly proper way
good question hey folks those of you
that lead those of you that run
organizations and maybe you own the
business your job as a leader is to
serve real leadership is serving those
on your team and so when a young man
young woman comes in like that you don't
have an option now I've had them come in
and tell me some
cockamamie story that you know somebody
offered them three times what they were
worth and I'm like dude this is not
going to work out because honestly your
marketplace value is not there
I mean I'll as your mentor I'm going to
mentor you serving you I've told them
but other times I just go hey I hope you
pack your desk it's a great offer you
know I care about our folks and I care
about them having a good life whether or
not it's here turns out you cannot work
here and still go to heaven it's not a
cult this is the Dave Ramsey